facing backlash from conservatives after
banning all political ads CEO Jack
Dorsey arguing the move quote isn't
about free expression and an apparent
shot at Facebook Dorsey blasting other
platforms for not doing the same
this comes after Democrats attacked Mark
Zuckerberg last week over president
Trump's social media advertising the
Trump campaign calling out Twitter
saying quote Twitter bans political ads
and yet another attempt by the left is
silenced Trump and conservatives
wouldn't be surprised if Twitter lifted
the ban after 2020 okay we're gonna kick
it around the table in the break and
then I got off track yeah you're trying
to build up some kind of concern for
this story things pretty interesting let
me go to you first Emily just from the
standpoint of do you think it's good for
public debate for to have a debate about
freedom of expression because you
basically you have two of the biggest
tech companies taking very different
opinions on this
yeah totally yes to that if there's some
type of actual public debate a national
conversation about something so
fundamental like that I think it's
excellent I think it's interesting that
Jack Dorsey has taken such a I am the
anti Facebook stance I am the antidote
we do it so much better here and there's
a lot of fundamental flaws with his
reasoning for example the fact that they
have now banned issue ads also and that
kind of to me will likely says that
they'll consider that like advocacy ads
one and so how do you decide I think
that's kind of a sticky wicket I would
say watch your mouth doctor for that
hurt no I lost my train of thought
sticky wicket
well anyway well to me that let's start
at point zero Deena which is I think
that Jack Dorsey must watch the five and
Mark Zuckerberg must not because I've
been saying I don't see why they don't
just do away with politically I'm sure
that that was because because it's
negligible in terms of their bottom line
and so you know they have an obligation
to the stockholders to make money but
this is not making money the reality is
that Zuckerberg doesn't seem to
understand from my perspective that he's
under
his brand by allowing political lies to
be put on his platform that to me
lessens the trust that the consumer has
and you know we have a very strong
relationship with Facebook cuz it gets
personal your friends family and stuff
and so now you guys say oh there there's
lies there's political lives who should
get to decide what's a lie that is true
I think a lot of people calling Facebook
a bunch of lies is because it's actually
another way to get information that
isn't the mainstream media and the left
and Democrats would like it just to come
from the New York Times and the water
when the right was always on Facebook oh
you're trying to silence ink and
conservatives now it's like oh yeah put
Trump's lies there please I'll be on it
I didn't even realize there were ads on
Twitter I don't I don't even see them
all I see are people screaming at each
other
Twitter's profits I believe are down
ninety five percent over last year
that's 90 that means if you made $100
last year you made five this year I
actually worked it out no one wants to
get near this tangled pile of screamers
because it's an its peak of Twitter as
we know has become an amplified edge of
discourse ten percent of the people on
Twitter do almost all the tweeting and
they're described as politically active
and left-leaning so what you're what
you're basically getting is you're
getting a campus sit-in every time you
go on Twitter that isn't it's not
Facebook when you go on Facebook it's a
fun platform because like you said you
see your families your family you see
your friends you see X X's you wonder
what they're doing you start thinking
about what it could've been it may be
but then on Twitter you get on there you
go ah
I hate this person I ate that person
this person hates me and then you just
go ask screw it I think it's I think
this is a consequence of politics in
general yeah people just like kind of
like except for the five new Twitter
announced this right after Facebook came
out with its earnings which were very
different from the ones that you just
described that Twitter had but what
about people that are lesser known
candidates or people that don't have a
lot of resources should they be banned
from using something like Facebook to
have a grassroots movement like I
believe AOC did yeah it handicaps
insurgents but to Juan's point Juan
doesn't think Americans are smarter
to tell the difference between a lie and
the truth and I think we are I mean look
at the dog he's gonna run an ad with the
dog and you'd say you need a fact
checker to tell the Americans that's a
lie you know what I mean come on
stewardess one Jessie I'm going to
defend Emily's mom we don't need you
guys in the media a little liberal fact
checkers to tell us what to know about
what to see the TV the only pro
president he's allowed to just say
anything out why he can say with
everyone so we're smart enough to make
up our own minds but here's the point no
chemica arts are getting crushed on
raising money and they know they're
gonna get outspent by Republicans and
the Trump campaign so they call Jack and
they say Jack I'm begging you we need
your help here you got a band political
ads because we're gonna get crushed and
Jack has to look good jack says okay
we'll do it but everybody knows
political speech is the same thing as
free speech and we don't want Twitter
policing free smile also that they do by
doing this Twitter might get some of the
heat off of him from possible regulation
out of Washington because the Democrats
will be like oh we have to be nice to
Jack now yes
you know suggest you should be everybody
should be nice to everybody